Mr Fernfield welcome
I am
you will make a very good assistant no
he's evil we will protect you you have
the word of the most trusted institution
on Earth the Catholic Church
[Music]
Renfield your sole purpose in life is to
serve me now let's see
I just want a normal life again
[Music]
[Applause]
Robert Montague Renfield
let me explain I work for Dracula Count
Dracula
it's the real Dracula some call me the
dark one
other is the Lord of death so you bring
and people to eat well I do other stuff
like what washes Cape no the Cape is dry
clean only strictly yeah I will wear
this
I don't think he's such a bad guy but
you're never really gonna be free until
you face him I will no longer tolerate
abuse I deserve happiness
you deserve only suffering I will
unleash in all their doubts everyone you
care about will suffer because you will
if you trade me we have to stop him
Before Sunset
I
deserve happiness and I take full charge
thank you
you know when something crazy happens
and someone's like it's okay I've seen
way worse everything I saw you do today
is going to be my way worse my least
favorite part of the job